hey guys welcome to the Reuben report
according to the NSA documents i'm dave
rubin I've got kira soltanovich David
Nussbaum with me and we are going to
jump right into it okay the government
they are listening to your phone calls
their data mining your internet they
could be watching this right now which
would be very disturbing and a new study
came out this week Americans are idiots
basically and don't mind that the
government is is watching you and
listening to you and tracking you let's
take a look at some numbers okay privacy
verse security fifty six percent of
Americans considered it acceptable for
the NSA to get secret court orders to
track calls of millions of Americans to
investigate terrorism sixty-two percent
say it's more important for the federal
government to investigate possible
terror threats even that even if that
intrudes on our personal privacy
sixty-nine percent of Democrats and
sixty-two percent of republicans say
it's more important for the government
to investigate terrorist threats even at
the expense of personal privacy this
seems completely insane to me because if
we don't have our privacy what do we
have our American have we just given up
like is the government is it all over it
is the freedom of America and all that
stuff just out the window kyra as a
Soviet former USSR i immigrated to this
country you know time like the
Communists like must get moose and
squirrel remember wait really you are
born I was born there um I'm totally
cool with it it's like finally America
you guys are on board to the old Soviet
ways yeah and I'm cool the government
wants to check in on my facebook if
Obama likes a couple of my pictures you
don't i mean i'll be happy with this so
this is cool by me but isn't that why
your family probably left the USSR
because eeks yes but you know it worked
it worked back then where people were
scared people were you know you know
sitting up straight hands in their laps
fallen directions and i think that's
what this country needs and it was a
simpler life sort of like you know we
have one toilet paper in Russia
is it yeah yeah smirnoff you don't get a
yacht that was yakone yeah was in Russia
toilet paper has what do you think I
mean that those numbers seem crazy to me
that Americans are so willing to just
give up their privacy I've been spied on
my whole life you know I lived with my
parents until I was in my 20s and so
they they they made me keep the door
unlocked they would spy on me in the
middle the nights i smoke a lot of pot
yeah they wanted to make sure that I was
always a you know big brother was always
watching me yeah so um this isn't
anything new for me I've started writing
more in my diary so that's offline and I
think then I think everything will be
fine yeah yeah I blocked my mom on
facebook so I did and how did you have
that conversation because I would love
oh she does get rid of she doesn't know
she doesn't know she loves Facebook and
so you know she's all over that stuff
but she doesn't have some I blocks you
know if you post a picture on her thing
you know but as far as the NSA um yeah
I'm I don't really like being spied on
but if there's really not much I can do
i'll just take it offline i'm not on
facebook anyway we all know that we've
been spied on for years right this isn't
new so we just assumed it all these
years cuz right like this doesn't seem
that shocking to me that they've been
going through our emails i mean gmail
basically tells you that right right i
googled my way to get here right i don't
even know if i'm using that verbiage
correctly but like I whatever i'm map
questing my way to get here yeah and it
said can we will you allow us to
basically track where you're going hmmm
uh yeah cuz i want to get there yes yes
you can see you can watch me if that's
what gets your rocks off you can watch
me get to where i'm going to the reuben
report yeah but I automatically click on
that some sort of big open space that
they can just pull all the information
about everything yeah I'm doing in that
moment I have exam I'm surprised that I
have two comedians here who are so cool
with privacy sort of disappearing
because you know there there's gotta be
emails you guys have sent that you would
not that you're doing anything illegal
necessarily but that you don't want to
be you know you get some rogue agent at
the NSA blackmailing you okay no much
emails I send are all illegal good my
texts are illegal yeah yeah I mean they
don't don't don't spy on me anymore than
you would normally spy on me but it's
probably something really hardcore going
on yeah I think that what's going to
happen is and I think this is actually
good yeah because when something like
this opens up the floodgates and all of
a sudden everybody knows what's going on
now people can start making better
choices because there are certain apps
that i will not download on my phone
because i will read not always but once
in a while I'll read the agreement and
one of the apps i wanted to do I camera
for what it was but it was basically
allowing you to make free phone calls
all right absolutely sign me up and then
I read a little like hey by the way that
means we get to fist any pets you have a
minute that's what I read the fine print
and so they would have access to my
entire phone basically right so you know
what I didn't download that up so now
everybody will be more aware and maybe
this will maybe this will start some
sort of little mini revolution with
smartphones and with the way we use our
email that will start saying no yeah no
apps better figure out a new way to rob
and steal from us and figure out what we
buy what kind of chips I like right
because I don't want you to have access
to you know my dad's pin code which by
the way I don't have so please don't go
after right and you're the rare case of
someone that actually read that that 30
page thing that you just can click one
button like people are really like oh
yeah itunes i'm gonna read this whole
thing yeah the way down click accept and
i just we'll just worry about it later
everybody else is doing it exactly
that's how David dates also he just
scroll down to what the chick says and
he goes fine yeah I'll buy it for you
whatever you want what do you guys think
of Edward Snowden the guy who is the
whistleblower the leaker because people
are saying is your hero or is he a
traitor because you can only be one of
two things in America you know to be
fine there's no room for nuance or maybe
he's a little of something both but I've
seen a lot of people like Peter King
he's a congressman in New York saying
you know we what we should try him under
the Espionage Act because he's released
so many state secrets and people are
going to be under the threat of terror
and blah blah blah that seems kind of
crazy to me this all seems
good basically what do you guys think
about him I think he's gonna be judged
by America once he's on Dancing with the
Stars and then we can all chime in and
tell tell him what we really think about
him yeah I I don't think he's a hero and
I also don't think he should be tried
under espionage that seems a little
ridiculous yeah I think he's smart to go
to Hong Kong because if you're gonna be
stuck if you're gonna be snowed in
somewhere right am i right and there's
mongolian chicken that can't be a bad
thing yeah do they have the same kind of
food we have no we know yeah I'm sure
there's a thought was there yeah they
might but that's a smart place i would
go to talk to hong kong hello in batman
in the second Batman remember Batman
went all the way to hong kong to get
that guy remember him bring him back for
trial and Gotham so it's not like we
can't get this guy that's true is that
why you think he went because he's
waiting for Batman to pick him up I
think maybe that is it it's possible
it's genius yeah is it art imitating
life imitating art imitating life it's a
lot asked officious circle it really is
what do you think hero or traitor no I
don't have an opinion either way as far
as a hero or villain but or traitor I'm
a little concerned why he would do
something like this he's got this hot
pole dancer girlfriend they're living in
Hawaii they're enjoying their lifestyle
he's making 107 thousand dollars a year
I think leave well enough alone bang
you're beautiful stripper girlfriend and
and you know why why throw caution to
the wind yeah I do that see that's I
have an opinion on I think you're a
dummy for doing that right yeah right he
gave up a pretty cushy life in in Hawaii
with a stripper although why was he so
pale in Hawaii why would anyone that's
live that's the weird thing to me like I
know he's a neuter guy but why are you
so pays actually tan for an albino yeah
that is actually tan yeah you have a
great skin tone for someone from Russia
well hey this is a picture of Russian
people are a little redder means well
you're Burt and you look like you could
be from Morocco I'm a Soviet jus so I
have that dark menacing jus look ah yeah
yeah that's what thanks very menacing
very yeah
be a young turk actually my last name is
soltanovich the Sultan's are from Torino
saying sir yeah yeah well we did turkey
last weekend we're gonna let CNN handle
turkey because they're so good they're
so good do